you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calms
tactics trainer and I'm going to do a
group of three puzzles and just share my
thoughts along the way all right so in
this first one my impression is that it
should not be too difficult because
Black has a mate in one threat so this
limits our choices greatly yeah
so we have to hit hard at the black King
checks there isn't a knight check there
isn't a bishop check there's a rook
check and a queen check okay well it
probably has to be one of them I mean
trying to defend with f3 doesn't that
run into bishop check here this rook is
brought to life how are you looking
materialize okay white is also down to
minor pieces so this may be factors in
yeah this likely factors in maybe this
is a draw okay well let's look at the
crazy stuff Queen to h7 there's two
different ways to capture
all right let's see the morph I think
this is actually more forceful there is
no King move
there's Knight takes rook and Knight
here a knight here I know exactly what
to do you take the knight and its mate
so rook here Knight takes rook then
Queen here as crazy as it looks
that's actually drawing okay this is a
draw by perpetual check repetition of
position so it's gonna be rook to e8
Knight takes for a queen h7 King takes
Queen and now the idea of being Knight
f8 King h8 Knight g6 King h7 Knight f8
etc f8 in g6 the knight will cover these
two h-file squares and the bishop covers
g8 that must be what it is starting with
a rook check that's correct
Queen sac so that we can save the game
and bail out with this little perpetual
check puzzle solved
okay let's try puzzle to seen that type
of idea before with the knight bouncing
back and forth so that was helpful
seeing that idea once before where we
are staring at h2 here we're playing his
white okay well I'm looking at h2 Queen
takes here there it's not a main threat
King can always go here but what do we
have against Malak like we don't have
pressure on too much okay going here
allows Queen takes f2 let's look at some
forceful stuff any checks no checks in
this position okay can we maybe win the
Queen I don't think so h3 possibly h3 to
just shoo this night away material-wise
how we doing on two three four five six
balanced material
okay mmm what more to look at just this
has my attention right here the two
pieces in whites position
a ch3 to defend Queen takes f2 and we
throw a punch it's not the answer but it
may be a step in the direction h3 Knight
h6 appears to be the only safe square
for the knight h3 Knight h6 and then can
we huh wait a second might be something
quiet as they start oh man huh this is
how to say okay we might be allowing
black to capture on h2 with check yeah I
think that is the answer or this is the
idea to allow this capture there aren't
any checks against the black King I
should have also done a scan for
unprotected pieces this rook is
unprotected and we can target it Queen
to d4 so black would have to react to
that somehow notice the other thing our
queen is doing from d4 it spinning the
knight to the Queen she's unprotected as
well so Queen d4 observes some
unprotected stuff directly indirectly
and this sets up next h3 so Queen d4
let's just say rook to b7 there's then
h3 and we're picking up the knight
Knight moves we pick up the Queen on
Queen d4 King our queen d4 Queen takes
h2 King f1 there isn't a good follow-up
check for black and in that position
there's still two threats black needs to
address Queen takes rook and Queen takes
Knight this Bishop is an excellent
defender against you know the Queen
invading on h2 King just scoots over you
see these ideas when with uh well the
one thing that's coming to mind for me
is on
blackened when white goes forward with
the Yugoslav attack you'll see a Rick
move just to avoid a dark square bishop
exchange or in other words a Fein k-dog
Bishop preserving it is is very good
he's an excellent defender against major
peace pressure so I think we can allow
Queen takes h2o queen d4 with this idea
must be correct let's do it that is
right
quiet move to start and now the
follow-up is h3 and we're gonna scoop up
some material yeah taking advantage of
what the unprotected pieces in this case
there weren't any fancy checks to start
all right let's try one last one no boy
the Knights are involved um but I think
I see the solution I do I know I don't I
was thinking for a moment we just take
the knight and then push the pawn and
how do you stop the pond but that's not
correct because the Queen can always
revisit and d8 with check and be
controlling the promotion square and
just getting behind the pond we're not
we're not going to be winning that so
let's look at something that's also
forcing Queen takes Knight was writs
checked but how about just Queen here
huh I have to be a bit careful if our
Queen goes astray if she's not defending
d8 we have to worry about Queen d8 stuff
yeah and our King is getting checked a
bunch of times so I'd like to avoid that
black to move okay suppose we insert
this check we got have to covered so on
the check Knight block we just take the
knight queen check Knight f8 I assume
you f1 check Knight f1 what next
if we just come back here the night
blocks at least yeah we just repeat the
position so Queen check night f1 how
about then we can still insist on some
kind of a mate
with Queen f6 Queen f6 is threatening
Queen f2 King in the corner Queen takes
Knight also the Queen on f6 is
controlling d8 I'm thinking that this is
it Queen a one night f1 Queen f6 how to
stop mate if the knight moves we still
just give check and then get to e1 next
and it'll be leading to mate so I think
at that point after we go to a 1 and
then f6 White will need to play h3 and
we could go to f2 came to h2 and then
Queen takes Knight we're just gonna win
the night and well the game but I don't
think we're getting mate I don't think
we're winning the Queen so it must be
the winner of this this guy here okay
let's put it on the board that is
correct and now the Queen goes here that
is correct
I gave a check and then we pick up the
night that'll do it
okay well feel free to leave any
feedback to this video feel free to
share how you did with these three in
the comments section below it's been a
while since I did a group of three
puzzles let me know in the comments
section below and as usual I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye
you